suis persuadé que ça va jouer que les
résultats qui ont été revus largement la
baisse par le camp du président montre
bien qu'ils ont pris la mesure des
erreurs qu'ils commettent actuellement
sur ce sujet on ne peut pas traiter les
élus locaux comme on le fait ce sont des
gens sérieux des gens responsables
ce ne sont pas des fainéants ce sont des
personnes qui se donnent beaucoup
bénévolement pour leur territoire donc
on ne peut pas leur supprimer leurs
recettes sans leur parler d'avenir
on ne peut pas leur dire qu'ils sont
trop nombreux on peut paraît supprimer
la réserve parlementaire
enfin bref il ya un certain nombre de
décisions qui ont été prises sans aucune
négociation alors que le président nous
dit toujours qu'il va négocier
donc là je pense les a pas compris sur
le terrain c'est ma décision
il a vraiment commis à mon avis une
erreur il a essayé de rectifier les
erreurs de mitterrand et dieu sait s'il
en a fait des landes pardon tu sais s'il
en a fait du terrain aussi d'ailleurs
dieu sait si hollande en a fait mais je
pense qu'il a pas bien analysé tous les
points et que la ruralité les communes
c'est quelque chose d'important au
niveau national il n'y a pas que paris
et il faut penser à la ruralité et les
élus sont vraiment furieux et je pense
que ça se verra dans les urnes